in your book
ethics in the real world amazing book
people should check it out
very easy read 82 brief essays on things
that matter
one of the assays asks should robots
have rights you've written about this so
let me ask
should robots have rights if we
ever develop robots capable of
consciousness capable of having their
own internal
perspective on what's happening to them
so that their lives can go well or badly
for them
then robots should have rights until
that happens
they shouldn't so is consciousness
essentially a prerequisite to
suffering so everything that
possesses consciousness is capable of
suffering put another way
and if so what is consciousness
i certainly think that uh consciousness
is a prerequisite for suffering
you can't suffer if you're not conscious
um but is it true that every being that
is
conscious will suffer or
has to be capable of suffering i suppose
you could imagine a kind of
consciousness
especially if we can construct it
artificially that's capable of
experiencing
pleasure but just automatically cuts at
the consciousness when
when they're suffering sort of like you
know instant anesthesia as soon as
something is going to cause suffering
so that's possible um but
doesn't exist as far as we know on this
planet yet you asked what is
consciousness
philosophers often talk about it as
they're being a subject of experiences
so you and i and everybody listening to
this
is a subject of experience there is a
conscious subject who is
taking things in responding to it in
various ways
feeling good about it feeling bad about
it
and that's different from the kinds of
artificial intelligence we have now i
take out my phone i ask google
directions to where i'm going
google gives me the directions and i
choose to take a different way you know
google doesn't care it's not like i'm
offending
google or anything like that there is no
subject of experiences there
and i think that's the indication that
uh google the ai we have now is
is not conscious or at least that level
of ai is not conscious
and that's the way to think about it now
it may be difficult to tell of course
whether
a certain ai is or isn't conscious it
may mimic consciousness and we can't
tell if it's only mimicking it
or if it's the real thing but that's
what we're looking for is there
a subject of experience a perspective on
the world from which
things can go well or badly from that
perspective
so our idea what con of what suffering
looks like
comes from our just watching our selves
uh when we're in pain sort of um
or when we're experiencing pleasure it's
not only pleasure and pain
yes yes so and then you could actually
you could push back on this but i would
say that's how we kind of
build an intuition about animals
is we can infer the similarities between
humans and animals and so
infer that they're suffering or not
based on certain things
and they're conscious or not so
what if robots you mentioned google maps
and i've done this experiment so i work
in robotics just for my own self for
i have several roomba robots and i play
with different speech
interaction voice based interaction
and if the roomba or the robot or google
maps
shows any signs of pain like screaming
or moaning
or being displeased by something you've
done
that in my mind i can't help but
immediately upgrade it
and even when i myself programmed it in
just having another entity that's now
for the moment disjoint for me
showing signs of pain makes me feel like
it is conscious
like i immediately then the whatever the
uh i immediately realize that it's not
obviously but that feeling is
there so sort of i guess
i guess what do you think about a world
where google maps and roombas
are pretending to be conscious and we
descendants of apes are not smart enough
to realize they're not
or or whatever or that is conscious they
appear to be conscious
and so you then have to give them rights
the reason i'm asking that is that kind
of capability may be
closer than than we realize
yes that kind of capability may be
closer
but i don't think it follows that we
have to give them rights i suppose the
the argument for saying that in those
circumstances we should give them rights
is that if we
don't we'll harden ourselves
against other beings who are not robots
and who really do suffer
um that's a possibility that you know
if we get used to looking at a being
suffering uh and saying yeah
we don't have to do anything about that
that being doesn't have any rights maybe
we'll feel the same about
animals for instance and
interestingly among philosophers
and thinkers who denied
that we have any direct duties to
animals this includes people like thomas
aquinas and emmanuel
kant they did say
yes but still it's better not to be
cruel to them not because of the
suffering we're inflicting on the
animals
but because if we are we may develop a
cruel disposition
and this will be bad for humans you know
because we were more likely to be cruel
to other humans and that would be
wrong um so but you don't accept that
i don't accept that as a the basis of
the argument for why we shouldn't be
cruel to animals i think the base of the
argument for why we shouldn't be cruel
to animals is just that
we're inflicting suffering on them and
the suffering is a bad thing
um but possibly i might accept some sort
of parallel of that argument as a reason
why you shouldn't be cruel to these uh
robots that mimic the symptoms of pain
if if it's going to be harder for us to
distinguish
i would venture to say i'd like to
disagree with you
and with most people i think uh at the
risk of sounding crazy i would like to
say that if that roomba is dedicated
to faking the consciousness and the
suffering
i think we will it would be impossible
for us
i would i would like to apply the same
arguments with animals
to robots that they deserve rights in
that sense
now we might outlaw the addition of
those kinds of features
into rumors but once you do i think
i'm quite surprised by the upgrade
in consciousness that the display of
suffering
creates it's a totally open world but
i'd like to just
sort of the difference between animals
and other humans
is that in the robot case we've
added it in ourselves therefore we can
say something about
the how real it is but i would like to
say that the display of it is what makes
it real
and there's some i i'm not a philosopher
i'm not making that argument but i at
least like to add that as a possibility
and i've been surprised by it is all i'm
trying to sort of um
articulate poorly i suppose so there is
a philosophical
view um has been held about humans
which is rather like what you're talking
about and that's behaviorism
so behaviorism was employed both in
psychology people like b.f skinner was a
famous behaviorist
but in psychology it was more a kind of
a
what is it that makes this science well
you need to have behavior because that's
what you can observe you can't observe
consciousness
but in philosophy the view just defended
by people like gilbert ryle who was a
professor of philosophy at oxford wrote
a book called the concept of mind
in which uh you know in this kind of
phase this is in the 40s
of linguistic philosophy he said well
the meaning of a term is its use and we
use terms like
so-and-so is in pain when we see
somebody writhing or screaming or trying
to
escape some stimulus and that's the
meaning of the term so that's what it is
to be in pain
and you point to the behavior
and norman malcolm who was another
philosopher in the school
from cornell had had the view that you
know so
what is it to dream after all we can't
see other people's dreams
well when people wake up and say i've
just had a dream of
you know here i was undressed walking
down the main street or whatever it is
you've dreamt um that's what it is to
have a dream it's to basically to wake
up and recall
something so you could apply this to
what you're talking about and say so
what it is to be in pain is to exhibit
these symptoms of pain behavior
and therefore these robots
are in pain that's what the word means
but nowadays not many people think that
rile's kind of philosophical behaviorism
is really very plausible
so i think they would say the same about
your view so
yes i just spoke with noam chomsky
who basically was part of uh um
dismantling the behaviorist movement but
and i'm with that a hundred percent for
studying human behavior
but i am one of the few people in the
world
who has made roombas scream
in pain and
i just don't know what to do with that
empirical evidence
because it's hard sort of
philosophically i agree
but the only reason i philosophically
agree in that
case is because i was the programmer but
if somebody else was a programmer i'm
not sure i would be able to interpret
that well
so it's a i think it's a new world
that uh i was just curious what your
thoughts are for now you feel that
the display of the
what we can kind of intellectuals say is
a fake display of uh
suffering is not suffering that's right
that would be my view but that's
consistent of course with the idea that
it's part of our nature to respond to
this display if it's reasonably
authentically
done and therefore it's understandable
that people would feel this
um and maybe as i said it's even
a good thing that they do feel it and
you wouldn't want to harden yourself
against it because then you might
harden yourself against beings who are
really suffering
but there's this line you know so you
said once age
uh artificial general intelligence
system a human level intelligence system
become conscious
i guess if i could just linger on it now
i've wrote really dumb programs
that just say things that i told them to
say
but how do you know when uh
when a system like alexa which is
sufficiently complex that you can't
introspect of how it works
starts giving you signs of consciousness
through natural language that there
there's a there's a feeling there's
another entity there that's self-aware
that has a fear of death immortality
that has um
awareness of itself that we kind of
associate with other living creatures
i guess i'm sort of trying to do the
slippery slope from the very naive thing
where i started
into into something where it's
sufficiently a black box to where it's
starting
to feel like it's conscious where's that
threshold
where you would start getting
uncomfortable with the idea of
uh robots suffering do you think
i don't know enough about the
programming that would go into this
really to
to answer this question um but i presume
that somebody
who does know more about this could
could look at the program
and see whether we can explain the
behaviors
in a passimonious way that doesn't
require us
to suggest that some sort of
consciousness has emerged
or alternatively whether you're in a
situation where you say
i don't know how this is happening i the
program
does generate a kind of artificial
general intelligence which
is autonomous you know starts to do
things itself and is autonomous of the
basics programming that set it up
and so it's quite possible that actually
we have achieved
consciousness in a system of artificial
intelligence
sort of the the approach that i work
with most of the community is really
excited about
now is with learning methods so machine
learning
and the learning methods are
unfortunately are not
capable of revealing which is why
somebody like noam chomsky criticizes
them you've created powerful systems
that are able to do certain things
without understanding the
the theory the physics the science of
how it works
and so it's possible if those are the
kinds of methods that succeed we won't
be able to
know exactly sort of try to reduce
try to find whether this thing is
conscious or not this thing is
intelligent or not
it's simply giving when we talk to it it
displays wit
and humor and cleverness and
emotion and fear and then we won't be
able to say
where in the billions of nodes neurons
in this
artificial neural network is is the fear
coming from
so if in that case that's a really
interesting place where we do
now start to return to behaviorism and
say
yeah that's that's that is an
interesting
issue uh i would say that
if we have serious doubts uh and
think it might be conscious then we
ought to try to give it the benefit of
the doubt
um just as i would say with animals we i
think we can be highly confident that
uh vertebrates uh are conscious but when
we get down
and and some invertebrates like the
octopus but
but with insects it's much harder to be
to be uh confident of that i think we
should give them the benefit of the diet
where we can
which um means you know i think it would
be wrong to
torture an insect but um this doesn't
necessarily mean it's wrong to
slap a mosquito that's about to bite you
and stop you getting to sleep
so i think you you try to achieve some
balance in these circumstances of
uncertainty
you